it's great that we've managed to achieve
the target of getting everybody in the
in the one to nine groups
uh vaccinated by the by the deadline by
the time
a little bit ahead actually uh 32
million
uh people now have got their uh their
first dose which is which is
which is terrific um and we're going now
to the to the
the 45 to 49 uh group they're being
asked
to come forward and i just want to make
a very
important point about about where we are
with the
with the pandemic because clearly
everybody's been able
yesterday to uh to go to the public be
going to the
uh to the pub to to go shopping get a
haircut
and and so on and that's that's great
and the the numbers are
down of infections and hospitalizations
and and
uh and deaths but it is very very
important for everybody to
understand that the reduction in these
numbers in hospitalizations
and in deaths and in infections has not
been achieved by the vaccination program
people don't i think appreciate that
it's the lock down
that has been overwhelmingly important
in
delivering this improvement in uh in the
in the the pandemic and in the figures
that we're seeing
and so yes of course the vaccination
program has helped
but the bulk of the work in reducing the
disease has been done
by the lockdown so as we
unlock the result will inevitably be
that we
we will see more infection we uh
sadly we will see more hospitalization
and
and and deaths and people have just got
to
understand that at the moment i can't
see
any reason for us to
change the road map to deviate from the
the targets that we've
we've set ourselves and you know what
they are uh may the 17th
uh june the 21st the next uh
uh waymarks on the on the roadmap map
but it is very very important that if
we're to get there in the way that we
all want
that can people continue to be cautious
and they continue to exercise uh
restraint and
and just do the basic things to stop the
spread
of the of the virus so you know uh
washing your hands giving people plenty
of space
uh doing things in in fresh air as much
as you can
so enjoy yourself it seems to be your
message prime minister but do it with
caution yes i just think people need to
understand
that the success of the vaccine rollout
is great
but it's not just the vaccine rollout
that's called
causing the reduction in in deaths and
infection overwhelmingly
that's been delivered by the lockdown
now
we need to continue to be cautious and
be sensible
as we roll forward with the vaccination
program